critics are blasting an Environmental
Protection Agency proposal that they say
could allow asbestos back into some
products the plan rolled out this summer
would require EPA approval to use or
import the substance the agency says it
also prohibits uses for asbestos that
were previously legal but phased out
voluntarily but as Ana Warner shows us
critics say the agency is not doing
enough to protect Americans and she
joins us at the table to discuss and a
good morning good morning Gail there is
no ban on asbestos in the u.s. despite
the fact that it's a known carcinogen
and has caused tens of thousands of
deaths so the EPA says its new proposal
actually represents increased regulation
but some environmental and Public
Interest groups say the dangers of
asbestos are so well-known that anything
short of a ban is simply not enough I
remember vividly it was 2003 when my
husband Alan had a slight persistent
cough
Linda Reinstein says the hardest job she
ever had was caring for her husband who
died from mesothelioma an incurable
cancer caused by asbestos exposure the
second hardest she says has been trying
to get the substance banned it's
ludicrous and frankly as a widow I feel
it's criminal the EPA is proposing a
significant new use rule for asbestos
which would mandate EPA approval before
a business could start or resume
manufacturing importing or processing
asbestos but critics worry it could
allow the Trump administration to open
the door to new uses of the known
carcinogen what on earth new use could
we need in the United States no one in
their right mind would ever want to use
asbestos again what the EPA has done is
really a stopgap measure Environmental
Working Group attorney Melanie Benesh
says the EPA's new asbestos risk
assessment ignores major existing
sources of exposure in homes schools and
workplaces what's the practical effect
of that then the practical effect is
it's really cooking the books on the
level of risks that EPA is able to
identify and the less likely it is that
the EPA is going to institute a
comprehensive ban EPA officials argue
their proposal would act as a band
in a phone interview epa deputy
assistant administrator Nancy Beck said
without the rule new asbestos products
could go to market today without any
government approval
she told us were putting in place a
hammer a prohibition that doesn't exist
today but critics say the plan falls
short
EPA could also simply ban those uses and
then no one would be allowed to use them
well the court struck down an EPA ban on
asbestos in 1989 and EPA officials argue
they're now focused on regulations that
won't be overturned now if you'd like to
make a comment on the new proposed rules
the comment period for those rules ends
tomorrow so we've put a link to the
comment page on our website you can let
the government hear from you all our
viewers about what do you think about
asbestos should it be banned what should
they be doing so it is banned in a
number of countries it's been in about
55 countries around the world it's
actually surprising to know that it's
not banned in the United States I had no
idea yeah no it's a lot of people don't
yeah well viewers can go to CBS news.com
and weigh in I'm sure a lot of people
hold up Anna and Anna thank you